[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدث
[موسيقى]
عسكريه امريكيه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
ثلاثه مليار دولار تتضمنوا مدرعات من طراز
ونقلات الجنود المدرعه
والى العاصمه الروسيه موسكو التي قالت
اليوم انها ملتزمه بوقف احادي الجانب
لاطلاق النار في عموم اوكرانيا دخل اليوم
حيزه تنفيذ ويعد الاول من نوعه منذ بدء
الحرب في شباط فبراير من العام الماضي
وفي رام الله بالضفه الغربيه المحتله
وتمديد من السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
باجراءات انتقاميه اعلنتها اسرائيل ردا
على لجوء السلطه لمحكمه العدل الدوليه
للنظر في التبعات القانونيه للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
برنامج الجزيره الاستقصائيه يعرض لقطات
حصريه لعمليات نفذها مقاتلون كتيبه جنين
وعرين الاسود
عن اختراق السرايا للشباب عبر مجندين
مزدوجين
الاسود يتحدث عن الجاهزيه بجنود مجهولين
ويكشف عن مساومات للاستسلام
ردا على احاله ملف الاحتلال الى محكمه
العدل الدوليه اسرائيل تقر اجراءات
انتقاميه ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه تتضمن
الاستيلاء على ملايين الدولارات من عوائد
الضرائب وتجميد الانشاءات في مناطق بالدفع
والخارجيه والفلسطينيه تتعهدوا بمواصله
الحراك السياسيه والقانونيه لانهاء
الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
رغم دخول وقفه اطلاق النار الروسيه حيزه
فيه مؤشرات على استمرار القتال في
اوكرانيا
ملتزمه بالهدنه رغم قذف اوكرانيا مواقع
عسكريه روسيه كيف تقول انها هجمات روسيه
تستهدفت البنيه التحتيه في دنياك والاتحاد
الاوروبي يعتبر الهدنه الروسيه بلا
مصداقيه
بعد عبور مدمره امريكيه مضيفه ايوان بجين
تطالب واشنطن بالكف فورا عن تصعيد التوتر
والاضرار بالسلام و واشنط تقول ان منعا
دلاع حربا على المضيق يتطلب الدبلوماسيه
المباشره مع بيجين
في لقاءنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم السياقه الذي جاء
فيه اعلان موسكو عن وقف احادي الجانب
للنار لاطلاق النار في اوكرانيا والذي
يمثل اول هده كامله منذ بدء موسكو حرب على
اوكرانيا فبراير من العام الماضي الخطوه
الروسيه قبلت برفض من كيف وتشكيك من
عواصمها غربيه
يكون بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي والذي يقول ماذا وراء اعلان
روسيا المفاجئ مده مؤقته في اوكرانيا جاءت
النتيجه على النحو التاليه نحو 27% قالوا
انها رسائل للغرب للرغبه في السلام في حين
صوت نحوه 55% بالقول انها اعاده ترتيب
للصفوف على الجبهات
بينما رجح نحو 18 بالمئه ان يكون السبب هو
تهدئه الغضب في الداخل الروسي
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
تتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
كبر الجزيره ترصد الاوضاع في كتب ورئيس
وزراء الاقليم يتهم صربيا بعرقله الجهود
الدوليه للحوار
[موسيقى]
كشف تحقيق برنامج ما خفي اعظم ما الذي بث
على الجزيره عن تفاصيله ومشاهد حصريه
تتعلق ببعض عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه ضد الاحتلال والمستوطني
التي تصاعدت بشكل الملحوظ خلال الاشهر
الاخيره عرض التحقيق لقطات تبث لاول مره
عكست التطور الذي شهدته شهدته كتيبه جنين
التابعه لسرايا القدس الذراع العسكري
للجهاد الاسلامي وايضا مجموعه اعرين
الاسود
خارج الحسابات هو عنوانه تحقيق الجديد
لبرنامج ما خفيه اعظم التحقيق فتح ملف
تصاعدي عمليات المقاومات في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله خارج حسابات اسرائيل الامنيه
والسياسيه هذه صور حصريه عرضها التحقيق
لافراد من كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا
القدس الذراع العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
الكتيبه التي كانت افرادا معدودين قبل عام
ونصف من الان باتت اليوم تضم عشرات
المقاتلين في صفوفها
مئات من الشباب يريدون الالتحاق بصفوف
الكتيبه واكبر دليل على ذلك انك تجد قطعه
سلاح للشهيد يحملها بعده شخص اخر لا يوجد
لدينا قطعه سلاح للشهيد بقيات بدون رجل
يحملها هنا صور حصريه لعناصر من كاتبه
جنين اثناء اعدادهم قنابل وعبوات محليه
الصنع باساليب بدائيه وهنا يقومون بعمليه
تجريبها قبل ان يتم استخدامها فعلا في
استهداف الاليات الاسرائيليه كما تظهروا
هذه اللقطات التي نطقت قبل ايام من بث هذا
التحقيق
شراره المقاومه تمددت هنا في نابلس حيث
عرين الاسود نجح ما خفي اعظم في لقاء عدد
من مقاتلي العرين الذين ينتهيجون مؤخرا
سريه جديده في ظل الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
والتعقيدات الامنيه هذا احد مقاتلي العرين
الذي فشلت اسرائيل في اعتقاله مرات عده
لمشارته في تنفيذ عمليه اطلاق نار قرب
مستوطنه شرب شمرون ادت لمقتل جندي
اسرائيلي قبل قرابه ثلاثه اشهر
في الشارع
قدامهم ضد السيارات
والمقاتل معنا صاحب الاصلاح عليهم مخزن
كامل
الحمد لله رب العالمين
خارج الحدود وتسع كما تقول لضرب القيادات
المسؤوله في اي مكان نحن نعرف منذ زمن عن
وجود القيادات التي تدعم الارهاب وتضخ
الاموال يوزعون الاموال على كل من يرغب في
تنفيذ عمليه ارهابيه وعليه فان طريقه
الوحيده التي اراها هو عدم رؤيه هؤلاء
الاشخاص كبشري يعيشون مثلنا على وجه الارض
خلال التحقيق كشف الجناح العسكري للجهاد
الاسلامي عن عمليه نفذتها احبط من خلالها
اختراق اسرائيليا لصفوفه ووجه ضربه
مجند مزدوج من غزه حمل الرقم 106 نجح في
اختراق صفوف المخابرات الاسرائيليه وتضليل
حيث تمكن بعد اشهر من التضليل من لقاء
ضابط المخابرات الاسرائيليه في القدس
والعوده مره ثانيه الى غزه دون انكشاف
امره لكن الاهم هو نجاحه في تصوير ضابط
الشباب الذي التقيه وكشفه هويته الحقيقيه
وايضا كشف نوايا المخابرات الاسرائيليه في
استهداف عدد من قاده المقاومه واساليب
تجميدها
هذا وقد قال اكرم العجوري قائد وسرايا
القدس الجنح العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي في
مقابله مع البرنامج ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو وحكومه
الجديده يدركاني عدم قدره جيشهما على خوض
معارك مفتوحه وان اولويه نتنياهو هي اكمال
مشروع التطبيع وهدد الاجوري من تداعيات اي
تصعيد اسرائيليين في المنطقه
هو مشروع وهو مشروع اولوياته في التطبيعه
تطبيق المنطقه الان هو يعتقد اعلام تماما
انه جيشه غير قادر على خوض معارك مفتوحه
في المنطقه
في المنطقه المحور المقاومه
شيء كثير وما يظهر على لسان قاده المقام
في بنت تهديدات من تعب الاستعداداتهم شيء
متواضع ما يخبا له شيء كبير ويجب ان يعرف
ان اي معركه مفتوحه قادمه
ستكون لها ما لها بالنهايه من لاقول
من جانبه طلب قائد مجموعه عرين الاسود في
نابلس سلطه الفلسطينيه طالبها بالافراج عن
المعتقل لديها مصعب احد نشطاء العرين
البارزين والتوقف عن ملاحقه افراد
المجموعه وكشف ابو فلسطين في مقابله مع
البرنامج برنامج ما خفي اعظم عن عروض
بحواف زماليه وامتيازات تلقاها عناصر
العرين من السلطه الفلسطينيه لتسليم
سلاحهم مقابل الحفاظ على حياته
في حكم تفكيك العرين وعن
عروضات لتسليم انفسنا للاجهزه الامنيه
وذلك هذا خيار شخصي لكل شخص يريد ان يصل
نفسه
[موسيقى]
ولكن هناك بدل المسلم نفسه
دفعه شقه تفريغ في الاجهزه الامنيه
هذه العروض عليها
من تل ابيب
الاكاديميه والبحث السياسي هل تعتقد بان
هذا الوثائقي اظهر ان اسرائيل الان امام
ضفه الغربيه اخرى غير التي عرفتها في
السنوات الماضيه
معدلات العنف الضفه الغربيه
وهناك زياده من الشعور بالاحباط في الظفر
الغربيه بسبب قله التقدم تويوتا يارس لكو
الغياب بسبب غياب اي مفاوضات سلام بين
الفلسطينيين واسرائيل وكذلك هناك شعور
بالاحباط في الضفه الغربيه بسبب الفساد
الفساد داخل السلطه الفلسطينيه ومنظمه
التحرير واذا جمعنا هذه الاشياء الساويه
فان هذه الشعور بالاحباط وخشان ظهور مثل
هذه المجموعات وهذا لا يعني باننا لن نفعل
اي شيء
يتكلم لا يمكن توقع ذلك ولكن هذا مؤشر خلف
الفلسطينيين في الظفر الغربيه ايضا طبعا
ولكن مؤشر القلق هذا من الجانب الاسرائيلي
يبدو ان الحكومه الجديده وكذلك الحكومات
السابقه لا تعيره اهتماما همم خاصه ودقيقه
هذا غير منصف مقارنه الحكومه الجديده
بالحكومه القديمه
كان حاولوا تحسين العلاقات
مع السلطه الفلسطينيه ومنظم التحرير
الفلسطينيه ولكن علق الاربعاء هجمات
الارهابيه مختلفه حصلت بين مارس
في اسرائيل
في العلاقات
لا اعتقد ان الحكومه الجديده ستكون كارثه
الحكومه الجديده استرجع الامور اسوء
بالنسبه لمنظمه التحرير ولكن اعتقدنا
الحكومه السابقه حاولت افضل ما بامكانها
في مقابل في مواجهه الهجمات الارهابيه
والمخاوف الامنيه حكومه الكارثه الجديده
كما سميتها هل اعتقد بان
ستؤجج هذا النوع من العمليات داخل الضفه
الغربيه لان لا افق اطلاقا مع مثل هذه
الحكومه
ولكن عندما يكون الدينار الشخص من السيد
من غفير الذي
ذهب الى المسجد الاقصى
واحاول ان يستفز الفلسطينيين
فهذا هو الشخص عنصري طبعا هذه ضيفه زيت
على النار وهذه سيد الكراهيه في منطقه ولا
بدون قول ايضا انهم بعض المجموعات في
فلسطين لا تعترف باسرائيل باي محول وما
فعلنا وبتكنك اشخاص في الحكومه الجديده
ايضا
عنصريون الى حد كبير ويريد ساعه بين
الفلسطين فلسطينيين واسرائيل
ويبني مستوطنات غير خلينا نتلاقى
قانونيه وهذا فقط يزيد صب الزيت على النار
هل تعتقد من الناحيه الامنيه والعسكريه
البحته بان اسرائيل فاشله تماما لان في كل
مره تقتحم جنين او تقتحم نابلس تغتال بعض
العناصر ولكن الظاهره ظاهره المقاومه
المسلحه هناك لم تختفي
انها قد اخفقتها
انها نجحت في تقليل عدد عدد مثل هذه
الهجمات من
المتوجهه او ضد اسرائيل داخل اسرائيل
ومناطق التي سيطره عليه اسرائيل في الضفه
الغربيه لكن كما تعلمون قدر قدر اعتقادي
بانها لم تفشل هذه لكن هذا ليس طريقه
المستقبل
اليسا اليسا
الاحتلالات
غير الشرعيه في صفه الغربيه
الى استثمار مثل هذه الاحتجاجات وكذلك
الوضع في الضفه الغربيه وبعض مجموعه من
الحماس والجهات الاسلاميه الذي لا يعتقد
ان اسرائيل
موجود مثل هذه المجموعه
من غزه حسن لا في الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
اهلا وسهلا بك همم الا تعتقد بان الملفت
في هذا الوثائقي ان هناك فعلا جيل جديد من
المقاومين غير تقليديين في الضفه الغربيه
بالتاكيد يعني هذا هو جيل التغيير هذا
الجيل الذي اقتنع قناعه تامه انه لا يمكن
التعايش مع الاحتلال هذا الاحتلال مع
المشكله ليس بحكومه بقياده بني كفير او
حتى سيموتريتش المشكله ان هناك احتلال
يريد احلال هذا الشعب الفلسطيني معنا عن
هذه الارض واعاده نكبته مره جديده يكفي ان
ان نقول ان ليس فقط مشروع حلو للدولتين
انتهى منذ 10 منذ عقود ولكن
الرغبه الاسرائيليه بضم الضفه الغربيه
وانهاء التواجد الفلسطيني هذا ادركه همم
هذا الجيل الامر الثاني هذا الجيل ايضا هو
لديه طموحات مثل اي مثل اي شعب على هذه
الكره الارضيه ومع الثوره الاتصالات
والتقارب وهو يشاهد ماذا يحدث في دول
العالم لماذا هو الا ان هناك احتلال يمنعه
ولذلك هذا الجيل عندما يقول همم المقاتل
في كتيبه جنين لم نجد بندقيه استشهد
صاحبها الا هناك يعني يح من بعد هذا هو
هذا معناه ان الحاضنه الشعبي مهما حاولت
اسرائيل ان تذهب بهم الى كاسر امواج هذه
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه او حتى استنزاف
يحولونها الى حرب استنزاف وحرب مفتوحه مع
الاحتلال وبالتالي هذا الجيل ايضا يعي
ادواته ويعيي استخداماته ولديه كثير من
الدوافع الذاتيه والوطنيه من اجل
الاستمرار لذلك الان همم هي انتفاضه ولكن
بشكل جديد بنسخه جديده تختلف عن عن السابق
لذلك انا اعتقد ان ما يحدث الان في الضفه
الغربيه وانطلاقه من جنين ومن كتيب الجنين
وانتقالها الى مدينه نابلس وعرين الاسود
وما حدث من عمليات انا اعتقد انه نابع من
قناعه قناع جيل كامل قد لم يكن عايش
الانتفاضات السابقه الفلسطينيه ولكنه عايش
الاحتلال واضراوه الاحتلال اللي هو
بالتالي لا يمكن لاسرائيل الا ان تهزم هذا
الجيل
نقطه مهمه في شهداء يعني كشفت الى نقطه
مهمه تتعلق بالحاضنه الشعبيه اخر
استطلاعات الراي وعمليات صبر الاراء في
الضفه الغربيه تؤكد بان اكثر من 70% من
الفلسطينيين يؤيدون الكفاح المسلح هل
تعتقد بان حتى اذا تحدثنا عن انتفاضه
مقبله فهي لن تكون انتفاضه كما عرفناها في
السابق
بالتاكيد همم يعني 70% هذا استطلاع ولكن
نحن اا هذا التقرير هذا الوثائقي اثبت
بشكل قاطع من خلال المشاهد ومن خلال هذه
الحصريات ان هناك تنامي في قوه المقاومه
بين الشباب بين كافه الشباب بدءا من رجل
واحد اسمه جميل العموري القائد في سرايا
القدس الذي اشعل الضفه الغربيه وانتصر في
معركه وحده معركه سيف القدس وبدات تتشكل
الكتيبه وهذه الاستراتيجيه التي الدائمه
لها من كافه الساحات الفلسطينيه وانتقالا
الى جبع الى نابلس الى طولكرم ومن ثم اللي
يظهر نوع جديد اسمه عرين الاسود تنظيم فوق
الحزبيه نحن اذا نقول ان لولا ان هناك
حاضنه شعبيه وكما اشار القائد العسكري
الاول في سرايا القدس همم اكرم العجوري ان
ااه البنيه الاجتماعيه والنفسيه في مخيم
جنين وايضا في البلده القديمه القديمه وفي
مدن الضفه بدات تكون قادره على ان مثل هذه
الحالات بل تطويرها
وتكريسه وبالتالي الشعب الفلسطيني
بالتاكيد لا خير لديه الا همم يعني
المواجهه وايضا المواجهه تفيده من ناحيه
سياسيه
نلاحظ هذه الظواهر الظواهر العسكريه نجد
ان هناك وحده حقيقيه داخل الميدان تفوق
الوحده السياسيه التي تفتقدها الحاله
السياسيه الفلسطينيه شكرا لك همم حسن
السياسي من غزه
[موسيقى]
صدق المجلس الامني والوزاري والاسرائيلي
المصغر للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه المعروف
باسم الكابينه صدق على فرد سلسله من
العقوبات على السلطه الفلسطينيه بسبب
توجهها لمحكمه العدل الدوليه الاسبوع
الماضي ومن بين هذه العقوبات خصمه نحو 39
مليون دولار من عائدات الضرائب المستحقه
لسلطه الفلسطينيه وتحويلها لعائلات
اسرائيليه اصيبوا في عمليات نفذها
الفلسطينيون كما تشمل الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه تجميد البناء الفلسطينيين
فيما تعرض بالمناطق جيم سي بالضفه الغربيه
تصديقه مجلس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الامني
مصغر على هذه الاجراءات العقابيه بحق
الفلسطينيين بذريعه التوجه لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه اكدت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه في بيان
لها ان اجراءات الاحتلال لن تثني الشعب
الفلسطيني وقيادته عن مواصله السياسيه
والقانوني لانهاء الاحتلال
في الحادي و30 من ديسمبر الماضي اقرت
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده بالاغلبيه
طلب دوله فلسطين فتوا قانونيه من محكمه
العدل الدوليه حول شرعيه الاحتلال في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ما الذي يعنيه طلبه
الفتوى هذا وتداعيات الاصدار في هذا العرض
[موسيقى]
الدوليه محكمه العدل الدوليه واضافه
لدورها في فضل النزاعات القانونيه تمتلك
سلطه اصدار فتاوى او ابداء الراي بشان
مسائل قانونيا
لكن الطلبه يجب ان يصدر عن الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده او مجلس الامن الدولي او اي
هيئه اخرى ضمن الامم المتحده يؤذن لها
توجيه مثل هذا الطلب بمعنى ان الدول لا
يمكنها طلب الفتوى مباشره من المحكمه فهل
الفتوى ملزمه الفتوى او الراي عاده غير
ملزم من الناحيه القانونيه لهيئه الامم
المتحده فهو مجرد فتوى قضائيه تتمثل بعرض
الراي القانوني من جانب المحكمه على
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
لكن اهميتها تنبع من انها صادره من اعلى
جهه قضائيه دوليه تتكون من قضاه ينتمون
الى اغلب النظم القانونيه في العالم
رغم عظمي الزاميتها فان الفتوى قد يترتب
عليها تداعيات دبلوماسيه دوليه وبان تشكل
مرجعيه بوصفها عرضا لموقف القانون الدولي
من هذه المساله ومن شانها ان تعرض قاده
الاحتلال لخطر الملاحقه القانونيه
[موسيقى]
لتدمير مواقع تابعه للجيش الاوكراني بعد
قصفها مواقع روسيه عاقبه دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره
ان الجيش الاوكراني وصل قصف التجمعات
السكنيه ومواقع الجيش الروسي رغم التزام
القوه الروسيه من جانبه اعتبر مفاوض
السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف
بورال اعلان بوتن وقفا لاطلاق النار في
اوكرانيا اعتبره يفتقر الى المصداقيه
مضيفا انه يبدو محاوله يبدو انه محاوله
روسيه لكسب الوقت لاعاده تجميعه قوتها
ومحاوله اصلاح سمعتها الدوليه المتضرره
من طرف واحد اعلنت روسيا هدمتها التي لم
تعترف بها اوكرانيا ثم اخذت موسكو تعدد
الخروقات الاوكرانيه اتهم الناطق باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الجانب الاوكراني
بالاستهداف المدفعي لمناطق سكنيه وعسكريه
روسيه في كل من محور كراسنو لمن ومنطقه
بيلو غروفكا بما تعرف روسيا بجمهوريه
لوغانسكي الشعبيه الى جانب بلده نوفو
بافلوكا بمقاطعه زبرجها فضلا عن قصف مدينه
دونيسك ثلاث مرات وذلك وفق مركز الدفاع
المشترك الموالي لروسيا بالمقاطعه قالت
روسيا ان الهدنه مرتبطه بالاحتفالات
الشرقيه بعيد الميلاد لكن موالينا لها
نفوا ان تعوق تلك الهدنه الرد على ما وصفه
زعيم الموالي لموسكو بالاستفزازات
الاوكرانيه او ان تكون فرصه لتحسين وضع
الجيش الاخراني ميدانيا قبيل الهدنه
بدقائق اشتعلت خطوط مواجهه وتحديدا في خير
سنه التي قالت الاوكرانيه انها استهدفت
بقصف روسي خلف قتلى وجرحى كما استهدفت
روسيا ايضا وفق الجانب الاوكراني مدنا
وبلدات في محور كوبينسك في مقاطعه خايف
مخلفه اصابات وحرائق لماذا رفضت كييف
الهدنه الروسيه اعتبرها الرئيس الاوكراني
غطاءا تحاول موسكو استخدامه لوقف تقدم
قوات بلاده في الجبهه الشرقيه واكد يوم
الخميس ان السبيل الوحيد لوقف الحرب هو
الانسحاب الروسي من كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الاعراض عن الهدنه الروسيه كان
ايضا راي واشنطن حيث اتهم الرئيس الامريكي
نظيره الروسي بالبحث من خلالها عن متنفس
لها وكذلك كان راي الاتحاد الاوروبي على
لسان مفوض السياسه الخارجيه جوزيف الذي
اعتبر الهدنه الاحاديه محاوله روسيه لشراء
الوقت لاعاده تجميع قوات روسيا واصلاح
سمعتها الدوليه المتضرره الحديث عن ازمه
بوت في الحرب الاوكرانيه لا يظهر في
تصريحات الحلفاء فقط ولكن في حديث
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين الذين يتوعدون بنزع
سلاح روسيا باستخدام الصواريخ حلفائهم
بعيده المدى ويتحدثون عما سيحمله الشتاء
والربيع من بشريات قريبه لمواطنهم ويبلغ
التعويل على الدعم الغربي بوزير الدفاع
الاوكراني حتى يعتبر بلاده باتت الشريكا
وعضوا في حلف الناتو بحكم الامر الواقع
ومعنى من كيف العقيد رومانكو سكرتير لجنه
الدفاع والامن القومي والاستخبارات في
البرلمان الاوكراني اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
فلسطين
هل نحن عمليا في هدنا الان
[موسيقى]
ليس بيننا وبين روسيا ولن نتفق عن اي هدنا
بل هم يستمروا بقصف مواقعنا ونحن نستمر في
الدفاع ونقوم بالرد بضربات ضد العدو ليس
لدينا ايودنا مع العدو اذا اعتبرناها هدنا
هل كنتم اول المبادرين بخلقها كما تقول
موسكو على الاقل
من وجهه نظر روسيا ممكن ان نعتقد باي شيء
لكن اننا نقدنا هدنا لم ننقد شيء من روسيا
من تشتاق اراضنا وتقصف المدنيين وتقتل
المواطنين الاوكراني والان تحاول ان تجد
غطاء في الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه التي باركت
قتل المدنيين الاوكرانيين وايه يتكلمون
عنهن لا نحتاج الى الهدنه نحتاج الى النصر
هل موقفكم من الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه التي
خذلتكم كما تقول كيف هو الذي يفسر عدم
احترام هذه الهدنه او عدم النظر فيها اصلا
توم وجيري
سؤال هنا في ان
روسيا تستخدم
التي تخضع
باركت قتل المدنيين الاوكرانيين والكنيسه
التي تحاول
الاوكراني في المجتمع الاوكراني
ويحاوله ان يقولوا يحاول ان يضغطوا على
المؤمنين والمتدينين في اوكرانيا ان الشعب
الاوكرانيا يرى جيدا اثر هذه الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الروسيه التي تبارك الاوكراني
لذلك هذه الخطوه هي عباره عن حرب اعلاميه
ودعائيه
كيف ممكن ان نؤمن
بيهدنا في وقت تقوم به القوات الروسيه قذف
وقتل المدنيين كان لدينا ال اعياد الميلاد
في الخامس والعشرين من ديسمبر واراء السنه
وكانوا يقصفون اثناء الاعياد المدنيين
ويختلون الاطفال والنساء عن اي كنيسه ممكن
ان نتحدث هنا الا يوجد في اوكرانيا من
يحتفل باعياد الميلاد في السابع من يناير
وبالتالي قد يكون هو يرغب في التقاط
الانفاس ولو قليله
او عقيده على المواطنين ولكن علينا ان
نقول ان
الاعياد ليس لها اي اثر على العمليات
العسكريه ولا تؤثر على علاقه بالمحتل
وكل يوم بنسبه لنا مهم حتى نتقرب للنصر
لذلك الهدنه او الاعلان عن الهدنه هي جزء
من معركه الكربوندا الروسيه وليس هناك اي
معنى اخر في هذا الهدنه ممكن يعلن بها في
القنوات الدعائيه التابعه للعدو انا كنت
اليوم على الجبهات واريد ان اقول ان اطلاق
التبادل اطلاق النار مستمر ولم يمارس هذه
الهدنه هو همم صفارات الانذار تستمر في
جميع المناطق الاوكرانيه ونحن نرى تهديدات
من
دوده الروسيه لذلك عن اي هدنه هنا ممكن ان
نتحدث نحن لا نشعر به ولا نؤمن بهذا نحن
نستمر بالدفاع عن المدنيين ونستمر بالحرب
والدفاع عن حريتنا ان هذه الهدنه هي مجرد
لعبه اعلاميه ليس اكثر نستمر بالمعارك
العسكريه حتى الان
جزيلا لك الان معنا من موسكو بافيلا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا
بك ما قيمه ما قيمه السيد ما قيمه هذه
الهدنه
اذا كان الاوكرانيون يقولون بان موسكو لا
تحترمها والعالم لا ينظر على انها فعلا
ذات مصداقيه
[موسيقى]
ان ان وقف الطاقه النار الموقر الطرفين لا
يعني شيء مهما وايضا رغم انه نستلقى انه
على ما يبدو ان هناك
-عكساش
نوع من
التظاهرات المعتده ولكن نوع من
انخفاض في معدلات القطار الى حد ما ولكن
هذا امر لن يطول لفتره طويله اذا ما حصل
وقف اطلاق النار حقيقي هذا يتطلب اراده
السياسيه من الجانبين ويتطلب الكثير من
التقنيات العسكريه اللي فك الاشتباك بين
القوات
التشكيل خطوط سيطره ولكن حاليا خط السيطره
همم
شهرين طبعا هناك قتال يجري على خط السيطره
هذا لكنه لا يتحرك كثيرا باي من اتجاهات
ولذلك اذا فقد اطلاق النار يعني ان هناك
هذا موجود فعلا حاليا ولكن ذلك لا يعني
التغيير
ولم يحصل المزيد من القطاع على ما يبدو في
المستقبل ولكن نعم روسيا تريد وقفه اطلاق
نار من حيث المبدا
روسيا تريد ذلك حيكون على خطوط السيطره
كما هي حاليا للمحافظه ولقاء على الاراضي
التي
سيطرت عليها روسيا خلال الاشهر الماضيه
وايضا تقريبا حوالي سنه من هذا الحرب في
اوكرانيا
اذا مو اسكت تكرر دائما نفس الشروط وقفه
اطلاق النار احادي بنفس المواصفات التي
تذكرها الان وحتى الرئيس بوتين عندما يعرض
مفاوضات او تسويه يقول مع مراعاه الوقائع
الجديده على الارض اذا في النهايه وكان
موسكو لا تريد تسويه ولا هدنه
السياسيه حاليا تبدو مستحيله ما قد يكون
ممكن هو النوع من وقفه اطلاق النار ولكن
حتى ذلك الان الامر صعب لان كل من الطرفين
لديهمات منك مختلف تماما حول ك- شكله وكيف
يكون وقف اطلاق النار
تريد تجميد للوضع الحالي
لتعاد التجميع قواتها والتنظيمه وهذا
يتطلب وقتها طويلا وليس بضعه ايام بالعده
سنوات
تعتقد
بانهم لديهم يد عليا ببعض اطراف النساء
وبالتالي يريدون دفع القوات الروسيه الى
الوراء وهذا يعني
بانه سيدنا المزيد من القتال قبل التواصل
لاين نوع من اتفاق الظمني
للتوصل الى همم
وقف اطلاق النار
دائما شكرا لك من موسكو
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البلاء
الروسيه وصول قطار يحمل جنودا ومعدات
روسيا الى بيلاروسيا واضافه الوزاره ان
القوات الروسيه البلاسيه المشتركه على اتم
الاستعداد للدفاع عن حدود ما سمته دوله
الاتحاد في حين اعلن مجلس الامن البلاسي
ان تجمع القوات الروسيه البلاسيه المشتركه
له اغراض دفاعيه فقط ويهدف الى حمايه
الحدود الغربيه بما سماه دوله الاتحاد
[موسيقى]
رفع عبور المدمر الامريكيه يو اس اس
موديل
التوتر والاضرار بالسلامي في المنطقه لكن
بيانا للبحريه الامريكيه قال ان الخطوه
تندرج في اطار التزام واشنطن بان تكون
منطقه المحيطين الهندي
ممكن
رسائل
مع الصين او ضحى بين البحريه الامريكيه ان
الغايه اظهار التزام الولايات المتحده بان
تكون منطقه المحيطين الهندي
قالت انه ينبغي للولايات المتحده الكف
فورا عن تصعيد التوتر والاضرار
حربيه امريكيه واحيانا لدول حليفه مثل
بريطانيا وكندا مرت المضيق خلال السنوات
الماضيه وسط غضب صينيه في كل مره وكثيرا
معتبرت بيجين لاختراق طائراتها للمجال
الجويه التايواني ردا على ما تسميه تصرفات
استفزازيه من حلفاء تايبي وعلى راسهم
الولايات المتحده شهد عام 2022 ارسال
الصين اكثر من 2700 طائره حربيه الى منطقه
الدفاع الجوي التايوانيه
ونفذت اكثر من 100 توغل بقذفات وسجلت بيبي
واحدا وسبعين التوغلا لاول مره بطائرات
مسيره صينيه خلال نفس السنه رجعها محلل
تايواني ان تكون الرسائل المبطنه من تكرار
الطلعات الجويه الصينيه هي اجبارتي على
البقاء في حاله تاهب دائم وشن حرب استنزاف
عليها
رسميا تبقي الولايات المتحده على ما
تسميها سياسه الغموض ولكن من الواضح ان
دعمها السياسي والعسكري
زائد لتايوان هو اللي كسري شوكه غرينتها
التنين المستيقظ قبل اسبوع اكد البنتاجون
انه سيزود تايبي بانظمه فولكانو المضاده
للدبابات وشاحنات وذخائر يدخلوا ذلك في
اطار الجهود المستمره لتايوان لتحديث
قواتها المسلحه والحفاظ على قدره دفاعيه
متماسكه ختم البيان ما يحدث هو اللعب
بالنار تحضر الصين التي اضحك اكبر تهديدا
امنيا يؤرق الشاشه والعسكريين الامريكيين
الصديق عبر مضيق تايوان لن تسمح اداره
الرئيس شجن كينج ان يمر مرور الكرام
وفي ظل هذه التطورات قال مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكيه جاك سوليمان ان منع
نشوبي حربا في مضيق تايوان يتطلب
الدبلوماسيه مع الصين ويجب جعل ذلك اولويه
مؤكدا وجود قطري لنشوب صراعا لكنه قال انه
من خلال الاشراف المسؤول يمكن ضمانه عدم
حدوث ذلك
فقره المتابعه بعد قليل نسال ضيف الحصاد
عن التداعيات المحتمله بمرور المدمر
الامريكيه عبر مضيق تايوان ودوافع واشنطن
لمثل هذه الخطوه
الرئيس الامريكي اليوم كلمه بمناسبه الذكر
الثانيه لاحداث السادس من يناير كانون
الثاني
الحفل في البيت الابيض 14 من ضباط الشرطه
المواطن الرئاسي وكان مسرعون امريكيون من
الحسبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي قد نظموا
فعاليه في الذكر الثانيه لاقتحام مبنى
الكونجرس في السادس من يناير كانون الثاني
عام 2021 وقد شاركت في الفاعليه رئيسه
مجلس النواب السابقه نانسي فلوسي وزعيم
الاقليه الديمقراطيه في المجلس الحكي
ومعنى الامن البيت الابيض مراسلتنا وجد
وقف اهلا بك وجد ما ابرز ما تم التاكيد
عليه في الحفل
تم التاكيد عليه حقيقه العباره التي قالها
الرئيس بايدن وشدد عليها هنا في البيت
الابيض اثناء هذا الحفل التكميمي وهي انه
لا مكان للعنف السياسي في الولايات
المتحده ولا مكان لحملات التخويف وترهيب
العاملين في قطاع الانتخابات
الرئيس جمع في هذه الفعاليه التكريميه جمع
بين تكريم همم اعضاء من شرطه الكابتل
الاحياء واثنان من الاموات الذين
بجراحه بالغه يوم هجوم السادس من يناير
على الكابتن وجمع بين ذلك وبين ايضا تكريم
الموظفون في الانتخابات الذين رفضوا
الخطوع لما وصفه بايدن بحملات الترهيب
والتخويف وتهديدهم هم وعائلاتهم بعكسي
نتائج
غابات عام 2020 عدد منهم دعاهم البيت
الابيض جاؤوا من ولايات عده وهي الولايات
التي حسمت النتيجه الانتخابيه والتي بحسب
الرئيس بايدن كانوا يتعرضون لتهديدات
وضغوط من اجل تغيير نتائج الانتخابات في
دوائرم الانتخابيه هؤلاء تم تكريمهم اليوم
طبعا الرئيس قال ان الهجوم على الكعبه على
رمز الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده تم
بسبب سلسله من الاكاذيب لم ياتي على ذكر
الرئيس السابق ترامب محمد ولكن كلنا نعلم
بان من نفذ الهجوم على مبنى الكابتل همم
في السادس من يناير كانوا من انصار الرئيس
ترامب انا ذاك عندما جاؤوا الى هنا الى
البيت الابيض خاطبهم وحكتهم على الذهاب
الى الكونغرس في يوم المصادقه على النتائج
الانتخابيه من قبل اعضاء الكونغرس
من البيت الابيض
الى موضوعا اخر فقد قال رئيس وزراء اقليم
كوسوفو للجزيره ان حكومه بلاده منحت ابناء
الجاليه الصربيه الشماليه البلاد مهله
لتسليم لوحات سياراتهم الصادره من جمهوريه
صربيا المجاوره تنتهي ربيع هذا العام
وذلك حتى ربيع هذا العام لاننا نريد ان
نمنحه وقتا للاتفاق بين صربيا وهو امر
ضروري جدا من اجل تطويع العلاقات بينهما
وكبادره حسني نيه من جانبنا قلنا اننا
غرامات على من يملكون سيارات تحمل هذه
اللوحات حتى الربيع المقبل لا حل وسطا في
تطبيق
ان هذا الامر عملي اذا توافرت الاراده
وخاصه اذا خلط الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو
واشنطن في هذا الامر بشكل مكثف
قالت قوته وحفظ السلامه التي يقودها
الناتو في كسوفو انها لا تنوي زياده عدد
جنودها ولم تتلقى اي طلب رسميا بذلك من
حكومه برستينا وتهم رئيس وزراء جمهوريه
كوسوفو البان كورتي اتهم صربيا بعرقله
الجهود الدوليه للحوار في ظل عوده الهدوء
الميداني للمناطق الشماليه الحدوديه
في بلده متروفيتسا الشماليه كوسوفو الذي
يمر فوق نهر ويفصل البلده الى جزئين جزءا
جنوبي تقتله اغلبيه البانيه مسلمه نسمع
المواطنين الان يؤدون صلاه الجمعه في هذا
المسجد الذي نراه امامنا وعلى الجانب
الاخر في الجزء الشمالي على بعد عشرات
الامطار فقط نرى الجزء الذي تقتنه اغلبيه
سلبيه يستعد للناس لاحيائي ليله عيد
الميلاد حسب تقويم الارثوذكسي بعد ساعه
قليله من الان هذا المشهد يلخص حقيقه
النزاعات والتوترات العرقيه والدينيه في
هذه المنطقه من كتب التوترات التي شهدناها
ميدانيا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه من خلال
الحواجز التي نصبها ناشدون سر باحتجاجا
على بعض القرارات التي اتخذتها حكومه قبل
ان تفكك قوات قوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها
حلف شمال الاطلسي اخر هذه حواجز خلال
الساعات الماضيه استعدادا لوصول المبعوثين
الاوروبي والامريكي الى المنطقه الاسبوع
المقبل لاجراء حوارات سياسيه بغيه ايجاد
ايطالي حلل ينهي امكانيه التجدد مثلي هذه
التوترات في المستقبل محمد المدهون
الجزيره من بلده ميتروفيتسا شماليه كوسوفو
اعوذ بكم الان الى ملف التحركات العسكريه
في مدينه تايوان على ضوء عبوري مدمره
امريكيه المضيقه ضمن ما سمته واشنطن نشاطا
روتينيه في السنوات القليله الماضيه عبرت
مضيق تايوان سفن حربيه امريكيه وفي بعض
الاحيان سفن تابعه لدول حليفه مثل
البريطانيا او كندا اثار حفيظه الصين التي
تطالب بالسياده على الجزيره غالبا ما تعزل
الولايات المتحده نشاطها العسكريه قربتين
الى ما تقول انه التزامتها بابقاء منطقه
المحيطين الهندي
مفتوحه في المقابل وعلى واقع العلاقات
المتوتره اساسا بين بيجيل وكيفيه ضعف
الجيش الصيني منذ العام الماضي منوراته
العسكريه
حول تايوان وجاءت تدريباته الاخيره غداه
اقراري قانوني تفويض الدفاع الوطنيه
الامريكيه والذي يسمح بمبيعات اسلحه فوريه
لتايوان تصل قيمتها الى 10 مليارات دولار
تتبع واشنطن سياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي
ازاء ايفي فهي لا تقيمه علاقات دبلوماسيه
رسميه معها لكنها هي اكبر مزود لها
بالاسلحه لتعزيز قدراتها الدفاعيه
لا تخفي الولايات المتحده خلقها ازاءه
زائد الضغوط العسكريه والدبلوماسيه
والاقتصاديه الصينيه على تايوان في
السنوات الاخيره لكن الصين تشكو في
المقابل من تحركات عسكريه وادي دبلوماسيه
امريكيه على صله بتيوان تقول انها من
شانها الاضرار بالسلام والاستقرار في
المنطقه في مايو ايار الماضي اثار الرئيس
الامريكي غضب الصين وذلك حين قال ان بلاده
لن تتوانى عن التداخل عسكريا للدفاع عن
تايوان اذا ما شلت الصين وجوما عسكريا
عليهن لكن منسوب التوتر بين واشنطن وبجين
ارتفع بشكل غير مسبوق بعد زياره رئيسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي السابقه نانسي
فيلوسي في تايوان في اغسطس بالماضي ينضم
الينا الان من مدينه في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
واستاد العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه فاس
والباحث غير في معهد سيجونغ في السيول
اهلا وسهلا بك
مجرد مرور مدمره امريكيه في مضيق تايوان
هل يمكن ان يثير كل هذا الاشكال
في الحقيقه الامر كذلك وما نراه
الامور على مستويين بالنسبه
للمدن بعيد سيكون هناك ربما مزيد من
التصعيد
وعلى المثل بعيد ايضا الولايات المتحده
ترى في الصين
تحديايمنتها وجزء من مخاوفها لان الصين
ماتت اكثر قوه
عسكريه
واقتصادهم حتى في المستقبل المنظور يمكنها
ان تتحدى امريكا اقتصاديه لكن
المتحده ترى في خطواتها هذه
الخطوه الاولى للتحدث
الصين اما الصين فترى ما تقوم به من
الخطوات ومن حقها السيادي
الصين انفقت همم مليارات
وعلى اقتصادها لهذا السبب ترى ان محاوله
امريكا لاحتوائها اقتصاديا هو الغير عادل
وغير منصف ومحاوله للحد من نموها
الاقتصاديه الرئيس ترامب وعد في مقابله مع
بعض
بانه يعيده حاله النمو في الاقتصاد الصيني
الى حال من الطباطه والتراجع ما نراه الان
هو ممارسه السياسه على طريقه الوصول الى
حافه الهاويه والعوده من دون الوقوع فيها
وكل هذه المناورات العسكريه التي تتم
تراها الصين استفزازا
والسبب انك كده البلدتين اذا ما استطاعاه
المرحله على انهم ليس خائفين من الحرب وان
كلا منهما لا يهمه المجازفه والمخاطره
كقوه كبرى او قوه عظمى عند ذلك لن يضطر اي
بلد منهما للرضوخي لايه شروط سلام من
الطرف الاخر غصبا عن ارادته لهذا السبب كل
بلد يحاول ان يحصل لنفسه على سمعه من لا
يخاف ومن هو المقدام والذي لا يتراجع
واتباع مثل هذا المنطق حقيقه
وراثه المتحده تتبعه افكار الرا الراحل
تونس والذي وضع اسس سياسه الردع الامريكي
على الاقل في مرحله الستينيات والسبعينيات
والتي تحدى فيها
ال ان الميزه هي اللي صالح من يستطيع تحمل
عنصر
المخاطره لفرض قوته الرابعه المشكله هو ان
كده البلدين يبدو وكان مستعد
لتحمل المخاطر
والمجازفه لتحسين موقعه التفاوض من دون
الاهتمام باحتمالي ان يحدث خطر ما هو خطا
ما يؤدي الى تفاقم الوضع بشكل اكبر ولكن
الملفت سيد
ان الولايات المتحده والصين يؤكدان على
الخيار الدبلوماسي ولكنهما في المقابل
يصعدان نوعا ما التوتر العسكري كيف نفسر
ذلك
انت لسه
علاقه بهذا المنطق الذي كنا نتحدث عنه من
الناحيه العسكريه من المفيد ان تظهر بوجه
من لا يخاف من يجازف من يحاول الحصول على
افضل شروط في صفقه لان من يضرب كانه خائف
من الحرب هو الذي سيطر لتقديم التناسلات
في ذات الوقت على المستوى الطفل بان مثل
هذه الطريقه في المجازفه تحمل في ثناياها
مخاطر ايضا لان اي تعامل استراتيجي من هذا
النوع اي يتم طالب قد تؤدي الى عكس
المردود وعكس المطلوب لو ان اي من هذا
الطرفين الذي يحاول فرص شروط على الاخر لا
يطبقها على نفسه ف سيشكد مشكله على مستوى
القوه الناعمه والقوه الدبلوماسيه
المعايير المزدوجه قد ينتهي بها الامر الى
ان تكون مشكله لانك لا تستطيع ان تتنمر
على الاخرين وتكسر احترامهم وتكون لك
شعبيه بين الناس في نفس الوقت
والسبب هو ان التنمر العسكري واستخدام
اللغه الدبلوماسيه لا تتشابهان ولا
تتساوبان لكن الف من حيث القدره على
الدخول في في الصفقات التنمر هو الذي قد
ياتي بالنتائج وليس القوه الناعمه
اذن بهذا ننهي هذه المقابله شكرا لك سيتم
كيفماكي من باث
بهذا مشاهدين الكلام نكونوا قد وصلنا الى
نهايه الحصاد
استودعكم الله
ونلتقي في فترات اخباريه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]